go arrest
my name is bad welcome back to some more
happy wheels they made a new map called
ocarina of time I wanted to play it
because you know it's fun to play stuff
that's a good motivation wasn't it
alright doodoo doo doo doo doo doo doo
doo doo doo doo all right Stan all right
that was a horrible man I'm sorry okay
I'm actually gonna go with him all right
I'm gonna go and save Zelda
okay what does he say sorry I didn't
read it oh sorry
don't worry he's fine he's an elf
hey link the great Deku Tree has
summoned you it's quite an honor I know
don't question me oh oh what's that
you're never the master dog kill your
chicken [ __ ] you uh-oh I'm stuck
what is this [ __ ] I have to restart come
on buddy you can do it all right
front flip shut up
all right let's watch out for yo you
little [ __ ]
all right thou shalt save Hyrule from
evil find the tree spirit stones Mon
which lies inside my that's disgusting
not gonna go inside you own no I be
snapping lost my armor it's okay does it
look like there's a [ __ ] hospital
closed I don't think then don't
okay if you have trouble meeting go home
and and go this all right fine
probably go mais dad I lost my [ __ ]
arm do you want from me all right let's
keep going
I've got the tree spirit all right yeah
he's here front flip okay okay hello
link up snap oh oh hello link ahead
you'll find the death mountain home of
Garland's slay the Beast and release
notifier
Hey Carioca melech Death Mountain sounds
awesome
let's go that hey you you [ __ ] little
move out of my way I said oh no don't
attack me Oh No that little [ __ ] why
would he do that
come on I have to make this it's
embarrassing
let's try this again alright let's try
not to kill anyone
oh that's what you get if you don't kill
it when I'm sad I died look at my god
damn I had this I think this is too
difficult but you brought skip saying I
you want me to finish the map so let's
let's actually do that and this is a
pretty well-made map I got him got a
hand it front flip oh you see that [ __ ]
son they don't daddy careful holy [ __ ]
he threw a knife on me why would you do
that
all right let's try not kill anyone oh
okay fine
Oh oops sorry son alright let's try and
save a little boy BAM oh my is dead
that's how I roll [ __ ] alright son I
see you like that okay now we will take
this we would go up there like a boss of
course Oh master arms it's okay don't
really care all right we'll have one arm
left so it's okay alright carry a coal
Nick come on buddy you can do this this
is easy go that stairs
it's [ __ ] little [ __ ] once oh now
my arm you took it
hey stop you're robbing what alright
oops
Abby's new I can do this I know I can do
this
yes don't you dare do anything what the
hell is this oh it's a bomb no no back
off back off Oh is not coming I'm sorry
oh wait my back explode explode do it I
need you to explode
oh we're good never mind no ah fell in
the lava I'm an idiot
Oh still alive stop now I'm dead now I'm
definitely dead
I think it is let's check out our Sun
again it's too long I don't know I don't
really feel like alright the legacy of
quasi what if we get have here it's
taking forever alone what the hell it is
oh no we're Indiana Jones that's awesome
all right I just grind this [ __ ] just
like I ground my ladies just kidding all
right this is how you roll like a badass
that's how you die like a badass to hell
all of these are [ __ ] difficult come
on pump it down what is that
it's clicking and clacking oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah that's how you roll
like a bad ass [ __ ] bass front-flip
oh no probably shouldn't have done the
front flip is there too difficult I just
want [ __ ] up maps to be honest sort by
play cons and what do we got here boxing
robot all right
I've seen toasters do better but
toasters can't do anything how do I do
this
hi eject myself pump it Pump It pump up
oh snap I lost my arms it's okay now
pump it come on buddy come on buddy come
on buddy buddy is your second name how
do I check myself there we go there we
go and then now oh I can control him now
boom right in the scrotum you like that
you like that you like when I do that
yeah you like that you like that you
like that you like that how about that
how about that oh yeah that's how I get
[ __ ] that's how I get them oh all
right
let's dance I said you're here ha the
hair too happy to be happy - hey man you
know
Boogedy Boogedy be either yeah hey ha d
here the habitude oh we already play
this one
Angry Birds sounds lovely Segway guy
what what the hell I'm like this is
stupid I'm sorry they're taking way too
far ok I really play this one too I do
apologize
so house I have to get the big santa
clauss
all right it's taking a while to load
but it's alright saw ooh it's like made
for me push the bottom over the wall
come on you dirty bastards rod ain't got
all day
Oh what are you doing go far away he's
silly push the bottom for the wall it's
up all right let's go oh he's dead that
little [ __ ] dead alright uh this is
even about rides up and down how did you
do what the hell is going on I was
freaking crazy
neon Oh pleasure and I said don't do
anything stupid everywhere I don't care
fat ass for Sparta alright let's keep
doing this boom check I like dollar
check for Cal what's the point of this
is too easy
I would prefer if you did oh stop
all right he was right yes whoa what -
hear what - he'll I don't even know
anymore harpoon King have fun yeah I'm
sure we will all right son be careful
watch out for the hot [ __ ] if you take
one to the knee oh no oh no oh wow look
at me that's not good for anyone I have
not given up yet you sons of [ __ ]
alright let's try it again next I did
give up
no sim oh you see that well dad said
[Music]
yeah we made a son we made it harpoon
run version - you alright why not
stuffed well that was pretty close at a
[ __ ] cash and I'd run my son done
[ __ ] they can do this come on SADS bless
your team spirit
you [ __ ] disgrace I don't care close
doesn't win anything I don't even know
how were communicating know what am i I
said I'm gonna inject you right away got
a son John son you can do it I'm proud
of ya they say there was much attention
I'm March I dodge them [ __ ] at us dad
dodge him like a boss I guess
I took it to the knee and I took it out
now oh no no so cluck oh no you were
doing it wasn't bad some there
JB some wasn't bad all right keep going
keep going shot guitar you can do that
your candor this [ __ ] and John not so
disappointed
so disappointed we're gonna make this
sad okay go son
no no what you became one okay let's
just try to eject him right away
no I didn't do it I press the wrong
button oh no we didn't make it but
whatever that was close enough we should
know that big what do you got whisper
mad run what is this [ __ ] press C grab
it with space-time start really oh okay
I am riding a West back like a bus not
really like a bus oh no I lost my arm
pit area the Ginza ah we were all right
that's not Italian Oh Sabbats new how do
I go forward I have no well that's
backward oh no no no it's gonna do fans
I get all da road I'm sorry I'm so sorry
so sorry bout you guys
oh no trash can alright it's good I died
I this is a boss people to ride West bus
with a broke your the missing arm you
can do this come on West back Holly [ __ ]
oh no it's okay we're still going that's
ok up the hill about the help I know I
can't really grab it anymore I whatever
it is pretty comfortable I might
consider let's try it one more time
grab that [ __ ] no that's not how you
grab it I'm disappointed
oh now you got a sneeze coming I've got
a pretty bad come on sneeze now doing
best back mass bah come back here rush
back
that's son of a [ __ ] goddamn it all
right I guess I can practice my sexual
skills
this one's called oh yeah piggy slide
this one called just take me take me
right where spot you read all he lacks
my sexual moves he's come here RESPA I
know you want me
come here whisper oh come come come on
come on oh yeah oh yeah like these
movies about yes no I'm sorry it's our
best but don't leave me I'm sorry I can
change I love you I'm sorry okay the UM
cat oh I have enough played this before
Prezi whenever you're inside oh my lord
alright
whenever you're inside whole space by oh
no no no you're doing it wrong no oh no
my legs I didn't quite make it let's try
again still have this [ __ ] sneeze
coming come on sneeze alright now if you
can do it like a boss
[Music]
okay girls never do that again
crush council would be the last one for
this evening and we will play a Santa
clash catapult castle learn you dirty
peasants all right all right where you
say China cars run faster wait hunt oh
sorry no one passes by the all right
well I am [ __ ] Santa Claus II think I
care about don't play with a shield
stupid peasants oh no what did you know
it definitely [ __ ] up this oh oh there
on you dirty peasants technically
they're gonna run faster I tell ya get
out of my way you stupid night all right
gotta deliver these presents all right
be careful touch it gently
oh no that's not yeah that's definitely
not gently all right this one was
feeling froggy anywhere so snowman that
never played it stop it now that sounds
epic
we are terrorists of happy wheels don't
care pump it louder oh oh what the hell
all right I don't have any legs but does
it look like I care does it [ __ ] look
like I care
what's with this short custom I only
said custom stories but I can't seem to
be a lot of fun to play Prez said let's
do it I pressed that what the hell's
going on
slammed on [ __ ] all right what an
epic way Channel episode like and
favorite if you enjoy subscribe to come
about and I'll see you in the next
whatever video I decide to make up stuff
it will have stuff in it I promise
let them do this thing all of that could
be an explanation understand
[Music]